اذا اردت ان يزورك النوم عليك التوقف عن
النظر الى الساعه
تناظر الساعه
لانه ما بدناش ننام هي دراسه جديده
مشاهدينا من جامعه انديانا تؤكد ان هذه
الحاله تعيق عمليه النوم وتجعلها اكثر
صعوبه عن جذب بالفعل الدراسه اجريت على ما
يقرب من 5000 شخص وجدوا ان مراقبه الوقت
يعني المزيد المزيد من الارق بالفعل وهذا
الذي تول
دنا من الاجهاد
على فكره انا اذا صحيت بنص الليل مستحيل
اطلع بالساعه لاني بخاف يكون ضايل خمس
دقايق على رن المنبه انا اطلع انا افتح
الواتساب وافتح التويتر يلا حياه سعيده
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على
يوتيوبر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات